hello and welcome to this chest course
for beginners in this series we'll be
taking a look at openings for white and
black and trying to understand them at
the beginners level in this video we'll
start by looking at 1 b4 and how we can
try to fight against it it's always
important to take a look at our
opponents ideas and I think here white
is threatening to play d4 two pawns
taking control of the center of the
chest so with this idea in mind how can
we stop our opponent's best move d4
hopefully you found what I think the
best moves re5 and c5
to stop our opponent from playing what
might be one of the best folks in this
course we're going to be focusing on e5
to start
with this move your pieces can be more
quickly developed after E 5 most common
move is Knight f3 in other videos we'll
take a look at other choices but we'll
start with the most common both that's
what you're gonna base out it gets most
of the time so Knight f3 attacks are
unprotected ePHI pawn and our pawn now
needs to be protected we have a bunch of
ways to protect upon but most of them
are pretty bad so let's see if we can
find all the ways to save this pawn and
maybe we can think about what's the best
of it of all these choices so we could
play f6 you could play d6 we could play
Bishop d6 Queen e7 put in f7 maybe 96
once your choices to save this little
ePHI pawn
most of them are pretty terrible let's
go from worst to best
oh my pitied best so first of all we can
play f6 probably the worst choice
because you create a hole in your King's
house now if you ever try to live over
there be a little bit difficult with
this open window that you've created and
even before we castle there's another
open window that the f1 is supposed to
be covering and now think your Kings not
gonna really like what's gonna happen to
it
for instance white could even do
something kind of crazy sacrifices night
but now your king is gonna come up here
it's a pretty big attacks it's check
yeah it's not a very good place for your
king to be you try to block with your G
pawn but very typical double attack
happens broke it at the very least yeah
let's not try to play f6 if we can help
it so let's take that off the table it's
probably not the best choice now let's
take a look take a look at the other
choices so next I think worst move would
be maybe Queen e7
at least we protect our pawn but your
bishops gonna be mad at you son make the
vision mad if you don't have to so let's
take that one off the table Queen f6
also pretty bad move in Knights supposed
to go to the center supposed to use the
f6 square you've stole it for him
so maybe that's not the best move
also your queen is that supposed to be
out early later that you might poke you
might poke you yeah
your queen just shouldn't be out before
there other pieces let's take that
option off as well that leaves us with a
few other choices they're getting better
these choices probably don't lose on the
spot next worst choice would be Bishop
d6 saves your pawn again but now the
bishops brother is mad at him the c8
Bishop he's supposed to move the pawn so
we can escape but now let's try that no
it's not gonna let us do it the bishop
is blocking the pawn and this guy's kind
of stuck you can try b6 if we should be
7 so this position is more reasonable
than the other choice is on our list
that we looked at so far but let's say
also not really the best choice so we'll
just take that off our list now we're
stuck with the last two choices that
that defend the pawn that is d6 the Fila
door opening not a bad choice we're not
gonna go over in the series because you
do lock in your Bishop from maybe a me
at the white side of the chessboard so
easily but this is a valid option
it's our block try but we won't focus on
on a inter series GP or locking up your
visual so we'll focus on the most
typical move 96
attacks upon a knight protects upon okay
pretty balanced here White has a lot of
choices that are that are pretty good
but we'll focus on the top for better
Knight c3 Bishop c4 Bishop e5 or d4 so
all well each of these choices will have
a video in the future but for now today
we'll take a look at Bishop c4 the
Italian opening I think at the club
level this is probably more popular than
the other three choices and I think it's
because there's a lot of cheap shots
that white has against your f7 pawn
there's a lot of just you know if you're
not careful some something bad would
happen on f7 it is only protected by a
little baby king so there's a bit of a
tender spot and because I think there's
a lot of cheap knock outs this is
probably wife's very popular at the club
level also not bad at the higher at a
higher level as well so what do we do
about the Italian well in this course
we're gonna be taking a look at Bishop
c5 you're gonna hit their week at pawn
it's also guarded only by a BB King so
everyone is hitting this the weakness
and the other guys camp now the first
thing to note is that this pawn although
Polk is not ready to be captured if your
opponent tries to capture it
no big deal you just take it back might
be concerned about your king being
uncatchable but your opponent doesn't
have any way to attack the king anymore
so this Chuck just take it this check
just take it so not much to do
now after Bishop c5 white usually will
play on c3 why do you think white would
play seat
that's right he's preparing to send the
brother pawn two spaces forward and
fight for the center of the chest poor
now if we take on d4 they could take it
back of the c1 so now we know why white
played c3 just sent the pawn to d4 this
is a pretty good plan fighting for the
center of chessboard
however when white plays c3 there is a
downside who is moved who can find what
might be the downside to the c3 boo
did you find it yeah very good the night
is supposed to go to see three most
chess positions and here why just put
his pawn in the Knights path so the
knight is now locked up and so black
should try to exploit that with a
developing move attacking this d4 pawn
we need to get ready to castle anyway
but it's just nice that the pawn is
under attack and can't be protected by
the knight going to c3 white will
usually play d4 this saves his little
pawn because he creates a counter attack
on our fish on my Black is not very
careful he could be completely overrun
in the center of the chessboard and I
think this is where most beginners get
into a little bit of trouble with the
black pieces they they usually use it
with the bishops under attack and
they'll make a passive move my god it
should be six or Bishop e7 just save the
bishop in any random way but when you do
that first of all your pawn is hanging
on e5 it's unfortunate if you try to
take it so that's the first problem we
usually lose a pawn and second even if
we didn't lose the pawn it's usually not
a good solution when someone in chess
attacks your piece and you just run it
to a passive defensive position usually
when someone attacks you you got to
attack them back in chess so you're not
bullied
and here you should take this pawn on d4
and when they take it back they did
create that pawn - oh how we work so
hard to try to stop but don't worry
we're gonna tear it down in a second
first we do gotta save our bishop though
so we're to save the bishop again this
is where people make mistakes at the
beginner level you she'll just like I
don't pass it Bishop e6 move so they
just attacked your bishop and you just
run well that's not terrible but now
your opponent owns the center did their
goodness just rolled you Oh or just push
up you know and now your pieces are
starting to run away from the center
it's it's not looking good not really
what we want so we have to more or less
what we get attacked we have to find a
way to attack our point back and what
that is Bishop before check it's pretty
good move check
your opponent can't start ruling you
over with these pawns because their
kings in danger I have a bunch of ways
to save their king my c3 Bishop d2 maybe
92 I'll be suspicious but playable let's
focus on Bishop d2 we take it they take
it back well they have to take you with
the night because otherwise they're eat
wanna sing right if they take up their
queen just gobble that free pawn it's
kind of funny way to win okay
so instead they take what their knight
defending the pawn and now this is the
most important part over opening here
whenever you have whenever you're
fighting against a pawn duo you have to
try to destroy it it's too powerful
gotta tear it down is that our only
chance to tear it down how could we try
to tear it down
we've been find a good way to challenge
this pawn to go
if he found d5 well I'm very impressed
he found d5 this is a critical move
challenging the pawn duel
what we still had a chance if black was
a bit lazy just let's say did a normal
development moves like castle now these
two pawns will completely crush your
Knights let's say d5 oops now you're
running the e5 this hurts it hurts even
look at these Knights
Oh beerus like this don't get your
Knights even did for the center like
that you have to fight against pawn duos
as soon as you see them if it's possible
of course and here we we have this one
moment to challenge jump of d5 and now
the bishops under attack their pawns
under attack you know they would love to
rate a space advantage or be 5 but sorry
your Bishop is under attack buddy so
they have to take us
we can take it back and here I would say
chances are roughly balanced whiteheads
face advantage with his d4 pawn but on
the other hand that pawn might be a
little bit weak
there's no cheap defenders for him
there's no pawns that could come to that
little D four pawns protection so the d4
pawn is an isolated pawn he might be in
trouble in the endgame question is will
black live to see an endgame white does
have a space advantage and he has a lead
in development as well
RTS three pieces developed black only
has two so to me the chances are roughly
balanced or leave in the comments I'll
leave in the description section a model
game where black actually won this
position he was he managed to blockade
the center pawn with moves like ninety
seven c6 leader he was able to you know
challenged his center court and he was
able to block he did however white
probably wasn't forced to lose the game
and so the game is roughly equal and
that will conclude our beginner analysis
of the Italian opening let's review the
kind of the critical parts there's a lot
of critical parts but against the
Italian move I'm suggesting Bishop c5
don't worry about ninety five of course
it's hanging itself that that's a
typical thing I hear from my students
where they're very worried about ninety
five at all times no matter what they do
well as long as you don't play Knight
Knight f6 Knight if ninety five is it's
not safe so you don't have to worry
about it by the way even if they did
play Knight g5 it's not the end of the
world you can just play d5 and now the
the bishop is is not gonna help the
knight take on that set there's a lot of
theory though in that position so we're
sticking with Bishop c5 just avoiding
all that for the moment maybe later we
can do a video on it but for the moment
ninety five just blunders the night
and maybe your opponents might do this
on purpose if they're bad because they
might have this idea to do discovered
attack hitting the queen hitting the
bishop but doesn't work at all because
we can move the queen with our own
attack on the growth so of course if
they took the bishop a pretty silly
loose bro so one day saved the rook
guess real gift one now you're free to
just call up their pawn and they've lost
the knight on g5 the pawn on g2 the pawn
on d4 I've actually seen this at the
Scholastic tournaments maybe once or
twice actually that popular but I've
seen it happen in rated games and
actually black didn't find Queen takes
g2 and think they I forgot they took
with the bishop for the night that they
plundered their queen white actually
went on to win this losing position but
anyway don't tell fall for the
discovered intact just take on G to your
pawn soon resigned they've lost all
their pieces so yeah 95 nothing to worry
about because 95 sent a threat you don't
need to spend your time playing some h6
move you know the stopping Knight g5 if
it was truly such a threatening move I
guess h6 would be a requirement but yeah
first of all you don't have to put the
night bear on f6 a block g5 and second
even if you did this this is not again
it's not a winning move just d5 stops
the attack there's a lot of ideas here
but uh you know black is doing well at
the highest levels we're not to be so
worried about this move the that we'd
have to waste a tempo with h6 so instead
just Bishop c5 and now you might be
wondering well okay fine
let's send my opponent just castles now
I play Knight f6 at some point I should
play it right to castle and now my
Queens not defending g5 now what now
maybe they'll play Knight g5 now so
maybe I should have played h6 yeah this
doesn't actually work anymore
now that black is you know tempos
slightly different black was able to
develop the bishop before putting the
night out and so now f7 can be protected
by just cast
and the sacrifice night takes sometimes
we see it the Scholastic tournaments
isn't isn't a good idea for for the
white side white is spent so many tempo
one two three four five tempo to expose
your queen but now they don't have any
pieces that are developed to actually
attack you're exposed key yep
Queen h5 is protected is stopped by the
knight and you know if you really need
you can always bring to light say the
bishop to f7 if you really need that
many more defenders but no-one's even
attacking your pink so you don't need
more defenders thank you for joining me
at this beginner chess course leave in
the comments with what opening we should
cover next again these are gonna be
abbreviated so that they're they're
easier to digest thanks for watching